-We are now just
over a week away
from the most consequential
midterm elections
in recent memory
and Republicans have made
their priorities very clear --
continue spreading
conspiracy theories
about the 2020 election,
intimidate people trying to vote
in this election,
and claim preemptively
that the results
must be illegitimate,
if they lose.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
These are anxiety-ridden times,
so, let's start
with the good news.
Thanks to new,
relaxed COVID restrictions
in the building,
our cue card guy, Wally,
no longer has to wear
a face shield during the show.
Now, that's true
of everyone here,
but Wally's face shield
was different.
Want to tell them why, Wally?
-Yeah, mine had a tiny,
wet sponge on it.
-Wally's had a tiny,
[ Laughter ]
Wally, you want to tell them
why it had a tiny, wet sponge?
-Yeah, well, I couldn't lick my
fingers between each cue card,
so, I needed the sponge
for moisture.
[ Laughter ]
-He couldn't use his tongue...
...so, he had a tiny,
wet sponge.
He couldn't do this --
[ Laughter ]
...so we had to do this --
And, for over two years,
I've had to read cue cards
while looking at that,
thinking to myself,
"That sponge is a stand-in
for a human tongue,"
[ Laughter ]
and I dare anyone here,
I dare any person here
or watching
to see a mask today that's more
disgusting than that.
Happy [Bleep] Halloween,
everybody.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
My national nightmare is over.
[ Laughter ]
Moving on.
Wally, I said, moving on.
Ugh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Republicans have made it clear,
if they win back power,
they'll do things
like impeach Joe Biden,
pass a national abortion ban,
and threaten to detonate
the economy
to force cuts to Social Security
and Medicare.
But it's not just Congress
where pivotal elections
are being held.
Pro-Trump Republican election
deniers across the country
are running for key positions
that would allow them
to supervise elections
in swing states
and some are poised to win.
The Washington Post conducted
an exhaustive survey
and found that a majority
of GOP nominees
on the ballot this fall deny
or question the 2020 results,
and the website
FiveThirtyEight found
that most of those candidates
are likely to win.
-60% of Americans
are going to have
an election denier
on the ballot this fall.
Of the 552 Republican nominees
running for office,
200 have fully denied the
legitimacy of the 2020 election.
-We simply cannot have
a functioning democracy
where one party denies
the legitimacy
of any election they don't win.
You don't see Jets fans
spraying champagne
on each other,
claiming they beat
the Patriots yesterday,
[ Laughter ]
even though they lost 22-17.
Yeah, the Jets jokes
are back, baby!
[ Laughter and applause ]
After a red --
After a red-hot start
to the season,
the Jets lost to their bitter
division rivals
at home yesterday, so, this
morning, first thing I did,
I walked right
up to our security guard,
Jim Brier, and I said, "How
about those jets yesterday?"
And he said, "Stand back,
or I'll crush your head
like a peanut, joke man."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then I said, "Yes, sir,"
because I respect Jim,
because at no point did he wear
a tiny, wet sponge on his face.
[ Laughter ]
Take, for example,
the GOP's nominee
for secretary of state
in Arizona,
a guy named Mark Finchem.
Finchem was actually
at the Capitol on January 6th
and has been interviewed
by the January 6th Committee.
In fact, just a few weeks ago,
Finchem, who is currently
leading many polls
for secretary of state,
which supervises
Arizona's elections, tweeted...
...which is the worst
Mariah Carey cover
I've ever heard.
[ Laughter ]
And, of course, it will not
shock you to learn
that these lunatics
have absolutely
no evidence, whatsoever,
for their lies.
In fact, Finchem
was asked directly
by a reporter for Time magazine
if he would certify Biden
as the winner
of the 2024 election,
if Biden gets the most votes,
and this is how
the exchange went.
Finchem told the reporter...
Well, where were you looking,
in the crowd on January 6th?
[ Laughter ]
Do you think maybe,
if someone voted for Joe Biden,
they wouldn't want to say
that to you,
a [bleep] looney tune who asks
Santa for Christmas arrests?
[ Laughter ]
Other than that, solid logic.
That's his argument --
if you don't personally
know anyone who voted
for Joe Biden,
then, by logical extension,
no one voted for Joe Biden.
In fact,
now that you mention it,
if you never met Joe Biden
and you don't know anyone
who's met Joe Biden,
then how do you even know
Joe Biden exists?
[ Laughter ]
He's probably not even real.
That's why he gets stuck
on stage sometimes
and freezes in place.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He's actually just
a computer simulation
and what we're seeing
is a glitch.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, if you recently
bought a tech company,
that whole glitch thing
was a joke,
not something for you to post
and say, "Food for thought."
[ Laughter ]
And, sure enough,
all these stolen election lies
are having very real
consequences.
In Arizona, for example,
self-appointed poll watchers,
some with guns
and tactical gear,
have been loitering
near early voting dropboxes
to intimidate voters.
-These people waiting
in the dark hours
of Arizona nights...
What brings you out tonight?
...are part of an effort
by conservatives to watch --
critics say intimidate --
voters
as they drop early ballots
into dropboxes.
Arizona's secretary
of state's office
has referred six incidents
of potential voter intimidation
in these parking lots
to the FBI for investigation.
Some individuals have been
armed and masked.
-They're referencing
these people
did varying numbers
at two different dropboxes
in Maricopa County,
people sitting in lawn chairs
and then, some say,
they are camo-clad,
that they are intimidating,
that they have a clear intent
to intimidate.
-Alright, first of all,
why the [bleep]
are you wearing camouflage
in a parking lot?
[ Laughter ]
Why do they even sell
camouflage in Phoenix?
The only thing
you can blend in with,
wearing camouflage in Phoenix,
is all the other idiots
wearing camouflage in Phoenix.
[ Laughter ]
The whole point of camouflage is
to blend in.
If you wanted to hide
in a parking lot,
you should disguise yourself
as a shopping cart.
[ Laughter ]
[ Gruffly ] Mongoose,
why aren't you at your post?!
[ Southern accent ]
They rolled me back
into the car corral, sir.
[ Laughter ]
It continues to shock me,
how these guys continue to be
both incredibly
dangerous menaces
and also complete dip[bleep],
at the same time.
We are living in an era
of lethal dip[bleep].
[ Laughter ]
On the one hand, they're
accomplishing their mission
of scaring voters
away from dropboxes,
but, on the other hand,
they're sitting in lawn chairs,
wearing camouflage,
like a dude trying to catch
a gopher in his backyard.
[ Southern accent ]
You think you can eat
my petunias,
you bucktoothed son of a bitch,
you got another think coming.
[ Laughter ]
I've got a cooler full
of Natty Light
and no place to be.
Oh, damn it!
Honey, can you run to the store,
get more Natty Light?!
The gophers ran off
with it again!
[ Laughter ]
Let's not have any illusions
about who's fueling all
of this --
the MAGA cult
of election deniers led
by the GOP statewide candidates
in Arizona;
and, of course, Donald Trump,
who has continued
to spread deranged claims
about the dropboxes
on social media
and even reposted the specific
address of one of those boxes.
-Donald Trump himself has now
reposted videos and photos
on his social media account
of new, unfounded claims
by these dropbox watchers
and another repost of his
included the exact address
of one of those
Maricopa County dropboxes.
-Trump is now posting
the specific addresses
of ballot dropboxes in Arizona.
Do you know how out of your mind
obsessed you have to be
to even know the address
of a ballot dropbox?
I don't even know
the exact address
of my six-year-old's school.
I just drive around
until I find a building
with [bleep] drawings
in the window.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, not him.
He's got a real --
He's got a real talent.
[ Laughter ]
Got a real --
Got a real Claude Monet
in the house.
[ Laughter ]
At this point,
Trump's social me--
[ Laughing ] At this point,
Trump's social media accounts
are like scavenger hunts
for insane people.
It's...
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
You have to find a dropbox,
a Susan B. Anthony dollar,
and the severed head of a bird.
[ Laughter ]
And, if you need a hint
for where to find
a severed head,
I would check under a windmill
because,
[ Laughter ]
to a bird, a windmill --
the windmill is
the Freddy Krueger --
Freddy Krueger.
We love Freddy Krueger,
don't we, folks?
He was -- He was
a tough character.
He was a tough character.
[ Cheering and applause ]
But he cleaned up Elm Street.
He cleaned it up.
[ Laughter ]
No one gives him
any credit for that,
but he came in,
he killed all the kids,
and, now, Elm Street
is a nice place to live again.
[ Laughter ]
No more slumber party keeping
you up all night on Elm Street.
[ Laughter ]
I remember Freddy came up to me,
once, tears in his eyes,
[bleep] face, and he said to me,
[ Laughter ]
he said --
he said to me, he said,
"Sir, sir,
I may be hard to look at,
but at least I don't wear
a mask with a tiny,
wet sponge on it."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And I respect that.
[ Cheering ]
So true. So true.
Couldn't lick his fingers,
either,
because they're knives.
[ Laughter ]
Knife fingers, and he still
wouldn't do the wet sponge.
[ Laughter ]
He toughed it out
because he knew
a sponge would be gross
to look at.
[ Laughter ]
And Trump hasn't just been
egging on
the ballot dropbox crazies
in his base.
He's also been talking directly
to the candidates themselves,
encouraging them to double down
on his stolen election lies.
Take Arizona Senate candidate
Blake Masters.
When Masters was running
for the GOP nomination,
he said, in an ad,
that he thought Trump won
and even had a section
on his website
claiming the election
was stolen.
But then when it came time
to appeal to voters
in a general election,
he deleted that passage
from his website
and admitted,
in a televised debate,
that he didn't see any actual
evidence of vote tampering,
which infuriated Trump.
In fact, a film crew
following Masters
for a Tucker Carlson documentary
captured a phone call from Trump
in which Trump told Masters
to stand firm on the claim
that the 2020 election
was stolen.
-Mr. President,
how are you, sir?
Doing great.
[ Tender tune plays ]
Absolutely,
we stay with those people.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not going soft.
-I didn't think anything
could be more grating
than Trump talking,
but I underestimated
Speakerphone Trump.
[ Laughter ]
It really accentuates
just how much his throat
has deteriorated.
He sounds like he's been smoking
three packs of Marlboros
every day
and eating one.
[ Laughter ]
And, sure enough, the entire GOP
and their media apparatus are
in lockstep behind Trump.
In fact, they're now
even claiming, preemptively,
that any Democratic wins
in the midterms next week
must be illegitimate,
like, say,
if John Fetterman wins
the Senate race in Pennsylvania,
even though polls
have consistently shown him
leading Dr. Oz.
-It's not about the person.
It's about the party.
It's not about the individual.
It's about the group.
And, to prove it,
they can even run
mentally defective candidates
who can barely speak
and not only expect them
to [ Raising voice ] "win,"
but expect you to accept
the outcome,
no matter how transparently
absurd it is.
On November 9th,
they'll be telling you
that John Fetterman got
81 million votes in Pennsylvania
and they'll threaten
to put you in jail,
if you don't believe it.
Why wouldn't they do that?
It worked with Joe Biden.
-[ As Carlson ]
Why wouldn't they do that?
Why wouldn't they conspire
to steal an election
in Pennsylvania
and throw you in jail,
if you don't believe it?
Why wouldn't they come
to your house
and ask who you voted for
and, if you say Republican,
why wouldn't they take
your house away?
Why wouldn't they take your car
and all your money?
Why wouldn't they
take your dog?
Why wouldn't they take
your second, secret dog
[ Laughter ]
that's an exact replica
of your first dog,
that you keep in your basement
because you've been anticipating
that the leftist woke regime
would come to your house
and take your first dog?
[ Laughter ]
Why wouldn't they threaten
to put you in jail
or kick you off social media
or ban you
from your favorite restaurant,
Carrabba's Italian Grill,
[ Laughter ]
and, when you show up
to Carrabba's
in a fake mustache,
why wouldn't they point
and laugh and say,
"Did you really think
that would work?"
And then why wouldn't they drag
you into the parking lot
and make you sit next
to small bushes
you only later realize
were actually
camouflaged dip[bleep]
lawn chairs?
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is all, obviously, insane
and, to combat it,
the Democratic Party has turned
to, perhaps,
its most popular figure
for the last days
of the campaign --
Barack Obama, who's been out,
hitting the campaign trail
to push back on Republican
conspiracy theories,
like, at recent rallies
for Wisconsin Senate candidate
Mandela Barnes
and Michigan Governor
Gretchen Whitmer.
-Mandela's opponent
has done more
than just
about anybody in Congress
to spread conspiracy theories
about the 2020 election.
I mean, he has a gold medal
[ Laughter ]
in that event.
If that doesn't
elicit uniform outrage,
what will?
What does it take?
The other day, a video came out
of Governor Whitmer's opponent,
claiming that Democrats
have been working, for decades,
to topple the United States
because they're still upset
about losing the Civil War.
[ Laughter ]
And that COVID restrictions
were part of some master plan
to do this.
Now, first of all,
what?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
What -- What?!
[ Scoffs ]
What?!
[ Laughter ]
-Whatever else you may
think of him,
you can't help but love
stand-up comedy Obama.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean,
clearly working on material
for his new Netflix special...
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's just nice to see
a politician have
a normal human reaction to how
utterly deranged this all is.
I wish we could use that
as a reaction clip
for everything going forward.
-On November 9th,
they'll be telling you
that John Fetterman got
81 million votes in Pennsylvania
and they'll threaten
to put you in jail,
if you don't believe it.
-What?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
The stakes of this midterm
election couldn't be higher.
Republicans have made
that clear.
They've told us
what they plan to do
if they win back power,
both in Congress
and in key states
across the country,
and priority number one seems
to be rigging future elections
and laying the groundwork
for the next coup attempt.
They're already preemptively
claiming these elections
will be illegitimate,
if they lose.
Most people react
to those voter fraud claims
the same way I reacted
when I first saw Wally's tiny,
wet sponge, by saying...
-What?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up, so,
to make sure that you're good
to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at headcount.org
to check your voter registration
status or to register to vote.